plus de fric pour l'hôpital public
proclame une banderole déployée par les
soignants qui font face au président de
la république alors que la deuxième
vague de coronavirus frappe désormais le
pays
les départs de l'hôpital public pour le
privé ou tout autre domaine
professionnel se multiplient pourtant
selon le chef de l'état de l'argent il y
en a il y a eu tout un travail qui a été
fait quand même qui a permis d'aboutir
sur le ségur de la santé ce sont en
effet des actes ce ne sont pas que des
mots
c'est plus de 8 milliards
d'investissements par an ce qui n'a
jamais été fait jamais en septembre les
paramédicaux et les agents techniques
des hôpitaux publics et privés ont
touché 90 euros nets supplémentaires à
partir de mars 2021
leur fiche de paie affichera encore 93
euros nets de plus mais ces
augmentations de salaires suffisent
elles à un personnel soignant qui doit
s'adapter aux démissions qui claire sème
ses rangs on peut pas aller travailler
dans un service de réanimation du jour
au lendemain ça c'est pas faisable c'est
trop complexe et trop technique que ses
maîtres le passé à manger et mettre le
soignant en danger également
on n'est pas des pions on est à là on
est des humains et donc si on nous
respecte en tant qu'humain et caution
mais écoute peut-être qu'à ce moment là
ils arriveront à retrouver du personnel
pour une heure de travail
il faut arrêter de croire que il faut
nous appeler le à 17h convenir à
travailler à 19 heures on a une vie de
famille on est déçu mais on a une vie de
famille on a des enfants on a des maris
s'ils sont encore là s'ils sont toujours
restés il faut écouter les soignants
visiblement l'attractivité à l'emploi
escomptée par le ségur de la santé n'a
pas rencontré un franc succès dégoûté
par la technostructure les jeunes
soignants quitte l'hôpital
trente quatre nuls postes d'infirmières
vacants en réaction l'ap-hp décide de
presser le citron des soignants qui
reste passage en dix ou douze heures par
jour et à 48 heures par semaine fatigue
gare aux erreurs de soins pour
rééquilibrer les effectifs
l'assistance publique des hôpitaux de
paris ap hp lance une opération
séduction pour faire face à la deuxième
vague dans 39 hôpitaux franciliens 500
postes d'infirmiers ou des soignants ce
sont ouverts avec des conditions de
travail améliorées
et primes d'installation places en
crèche l'assistance publique des
hôpitaux de marseille ap hm recherche
également 200 infirmières une perte de
motivation générale face à un quotidien
toujours plus complexe à gérer en raison
de la crise du coït 19 et des promesses
qui tarde à se concrétiser